cnn had a segment with a trans athlete
they call this person i think on on the
screen what do they say here
yeah trans female okay so they call this
person a trans
female athlete which i assume means it's
a male who identifies as a woman
but you see how sex and gender have once
again become interchangeable
after they spent the last i don't know
40 or 50 years telling us that sex and
gender are two different things and
they're not interchangeable
you know being a woman is not exactly
the same thing as being a female
and a person can be a female that
necessarily make them a woman
that's what they said for the last 40 or
50 years and now over the last couple of
years what they
they've gone back and uh and said never
mind actually it's the same
i'd always screamed at you for 50 years
that it's two different things but turns
out now basically it's interchangeable
woman female same thing sex gender same
thing
so but that's the least of the problems
i think with this segment and um
let's let's just listen to this madness
the simplistic version is
that those born male have a natural
physiological advantage that also
includes
differing levels of testosterone you
know the argument
your response to that is what yeah
it's uh it's a nonsense argument so
depends on how much time you want let me
get into the weeds because i can
literally spend hours on this how about
30 how about 30 seconds
yeah so the first thing is testosterone
your natural internally produced and
dodges testosterone has
zero impact on your athletic performance
and we know that
but we didn't know that until 2013
because everyone just assumed that while
testosterone is why men are bigger
stronger faster
but when we finally studied it there is
no relationship
between just natural testosterone and
performance so why is testosterone
banned
well every body produces a different
amount and when you add
to it through exogenous means doping
there is a performance advantage but
when you take a body's natural amount
and you drop below it
there tends to be a performance
disadvantage for example
in one study they found
in this elite set of male athletes
some men below the women's average for
testosterone
were competing at no competitive
disadvantage with men
that had 40 times as much testosterone
right but the first problem here maybe
the biggest problem are the glasses
there
who goes on on television wearing
glasses like that
now i know you might point out that i
have made some interesting fashion
choices
with what i choose to wear when i'm on
uh in front of the camera but come on
give me a break that's uh what
rainbow rainbow glasses
but this is what you what you're seeing
there is
the left doing what the left does um
and that is distracting from the main
point
and what they're going to do is but
really on any issue especially where
they know they have an indefensible
position which is
every issue uh particularly when it
comes to gender
they're going to hone in on one specific
argument and what they say
in that area will be false but it's also
going to be
almost entirely beside the point but
then the
the strategy is that the other side on
the right
we get sucked into having this argument
over this basically irrelevant detail
because what they're saying there is so
wrong and we can't we feel like we can't
leapfrog over that we have to you know
argue over that so
the claim that testosterone doesn't give
athletes an advantage is obviously
ridiculous
but it's almost beside the point we
could even it's not about
testosterone is just one one
minor advantage in comparison to all the
other advantages that men have
they don't even talk about
any of those other advantages now it's
all about testosterone
and so they're going to pull out all the
studies and they're going to say this
study over here so this about
testosterone
they're gonna start using a lot of
complicated sounding words like
exogenous
and all these kinds of words to make it
sound like they're um they have the
science supporting them and they're
taking a very nuanced and intelligent
position and this is all
what they're actually claiming is that
men
don't have any innate biological
advantage in sports
it is so insane it is as
crazy as claiming that the earth is flat
i know a lot of positions get compared
to that oh these are like flat earthers
no
this is actual flat eartherism this is
as crazy as that
it is that divorce from reality
obviously men have an advantage in
sports
that's why you take any sport and you
find
that that the best men are always
better than the best women in most
sports
i should say you want to make you want
to talk about gymnastics or those
it might be different but when it comes
to
the traditional competitive sports
racing
you know basketball football wrestling
boxing one-on-one
where it's all about strength and
stamina
pure athleticism men are always
the best men are always substantially
better than the best women and in fact
men a few notches down are going to be
substantially better than the best women
that's why you take any d3
uh basketball team from college and you
put them against the best wnba players
we all know they would dominate
the score would be 85 to zero
we all know that
go to any state look at the
the the track and field statistics and
records
in any state in the union anyone
and what you're going to find is that
all of the fastest times
belong to men always always
everywhere and for all time
why is that because men have dozens
and dozens of physical advantages and
it's and
testosterone isn't even the beginning of
it
you're talking about muscle structure
bone structure everything down
you know even things like women having
wider hips i mean things like that
every every part of us as
as as men is going to be going to be
different from women
we as as a man you are male down to your
very bones
literally and women are women down to
their bones
and all through that you find
differences
and in so many of these cases the
differences give
advantages to men in most competitive
sports
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated